there is simply no respite
while families sit on the earth and
mourn those buried beneath it
the digger keeps excavating fresh graves
ready for the dead about to join them
this industrial strip in the outskirts
of jakarta has been transformed into a
mass grave
covid has overwhelmed indonesia and the
dead
have overwhelmed the places to bury them
ten coffins arrive each hour shrink
wrapped in plastic
to protect those handling them the
gravediggers have been at work
non-stop
we are never giving up and our slogan is
maybe we're exhausted but we can never
give up
we feel afraid particularly we're afraid
of getting infected and bringing it to
our families
but this is our duty and there is
nothing we can do
indonesia's healthcare system is on the
point of collapse
hospitals are full patients spill out
into the streets
instead of isolation wards they use
tents
and they have run out of life-saving
oxygen patients must provide it
themselves
august sudamadi has brought his wife to
hospital they knew to come prepared
we bought everything we needed including
our own oxygen so we didn't increase the
burden on the hospital
since the oxygen supply in the hospital
is empty people who have oxygen are
getting treatment
but the hospital doesn't know where to
put patients without oxygen so often the
patient will get short of breath and die
indonesians have been left to fend for
themselves buying oxygen wherever they
can
in the pramica street market in jakarta
people search for unproven
potentially dangerous drugs a desperate
attempt to treat their relatives
themselves
because hospitals cannot
the archipelago is in the midst of a
covert catastrophe
the government was reluctant to impose
restrictions when cases began
rising and the delta variant has torn
through the population
only a tiny fraction have been
vaccinated even the few who have been
jabbed
frontline medical workers who've mainly
received china's cinevac vaccine
are dying the government says it will
change its vaccination policy
also the indonesian government will
provide the third dose of vaccines and
booster
to ensure the maximum protections toward
the healthcare
workers okay so there's not a particular
issue with
vaccines that are coming from china no
we started with uh vaccine from china
because that's available for
us and then we want to make sure that
the it it
gives the protections to the people if
it's not then it has to be booster
and it will apply to any vaccines that
will be fascinated but cases keep
soaring and the deaths keep coming
day has turned into night and still they
dig
tom sky news beijing